newly released video shows the deadly
ambush of American soldiers and is
raising new questions about the US
military mission in the African country
of Nazaire four Americans were killed in
the October ambush Isis released the
video is part of a propaganda campaign a
warning parts of this are disturbing and
graphic David Martin is at the Pentagon
David good morning good morning the
video is hard to watch because it shows
the final moments of American soldiers
fighting for their lives but it also
shows just how outgunned and overwhelmed
they were a helmet camera worn by one of
the American soldiers recorded the
ambush 11 American and 13 Azarian
soldiers were returning from what was
supposed to have been a low-risk Patrol
after the shooting stopped the camera
was taken off his body and released as
part of an Isis propaganda video the
Americans tried to take cover behind
their unarmored SUV with one of the
soldiers at the wheel they ran alongside
attempting to escape the kill zone they
fired colored smoke which would provide
some concealment and identify their
position do any friendly aircraft
overhead the Patrol was overwhelmed very
quickly was unable to get situational
awareness was unable to get its bearing
was unable to fall back to a covered and
concealed position one of them went down
another rush to his side and dragged him
back to the cover of the SUV their
position that the SUV was about to be
overrun so they did the only thing they
could ran to a position that might
provide better cover except for the
smoke from the grenades and a few scrub
trees there was no cover and no escape
the soldier wearing the helmet camera
went down soon the camera stopped moving
and some of the enemy fighters came into
view
then a final blast filled the frame from
what apparently was around fired at
point-blank range knowing that they were
asked to try and complete and execute
this type of mission with that type of
equipment I just I could not believe it
congressman Marc Veasey serves on the
House Armed Services Committee five
months after the attack they are waiting
for the final in vest
Gatien report we should have gotten this
information a long time ago while they
were asked to continue to go onto this
mission I think is something that we all
need to find out the answers could come
this week the commander of US troops in
Africa is scheduled to testify before
that house committee and the Pentagon is
expected to release the results of its
investigation
Brianna yet another source of pain for
the families of those soldiers David
thank you